Народився і почав плести.
Батьки займалися.
Батьки в колгоспі були.
Колгосп давав бутлі.
Бутилі п'яти-, десяти-,
двадцятилітрові обплітали.
Процес майже той самий:
тільки то бутель, а це — крісло.
Немає значення: збив каркас
і в'яжеш що там, що там.
Здебільшого під замовлення надсилаємо.
Ну і частину реалізуємо тут.
Здебільшого влітку користуємось можливістю,
що біля дороги живемо.
Приїзджають сюди відпочивати,
та й заходять купляти.
Як кажуть: «якщо нема роботи —
шукай в іншому місці».
І тому, здебільшого почали переходити на це.
Раніше садили тут
картоплю та кукурудзу.
Зараз вирощуємо лозу.
[Лоза] буває широколистою, вузьколистою і т.д.
Різна. Оцей сорт називається «Американка».
Він — тонший.
Товстіші колються,
а з тоншого плетуть з цілої лози.
Кума, притни мені там знизу,
будь ласкава, позаду тебе.
Ага, дякую.
Першим започаткував Кашко.
Він спочатку навчив своїх синів двох,
у нього два сини було.
Та він їх навчив, потім сусідів навчив.
Брат, кум, сват і так потихеньку,
потихеньку — все село.
І вчителі, і медики — після роботи
вони займаються лозоплетінням.
Ми багато один одному допомагаємо,
бо одна людина не встигне.
Тут за раз зібрати, а потім вдома він буде...
Також щось мені допомагатиме.
Виховується оця любов від кореня.
Приємно бачити працю.
І все зараз вдома треба приводити до ладу.
Є руни, а є — не руни.
Його треба харити,
листя зчинювати із нього.
Перебрати його по найтоншому, найтовстішому.
Далі стягнути, щоб прутття були однакової висоти.
З цим роботи хоч куй.
Далі варити у котлах. Далі чистити.
Дуже багато роботи.
♪ [співають народну пісню під час роботи] ♪
Оце все похарю, а далі позав'язувати
у такий бунтик.
Далі покласти у великий котел та
варити три години.
Через три години треба чистити шкурку.
А потім, аби сохло.
А далі — поколоти його.
Полюбили робити таку роботу.
Більше нема такого села, як у нас,
щоб займалися цим лозоплетінням.
Ми вже усе перебрали,склали, посортували.
Після того, як посортує, пов'яже —
тоді вже класти варити його.
Такі справи.
Як вода закипить,
кладемо туди лозу.
Їй треба три години,
щоб покипіла, і виймати.
Потім треба її раз висушити,
а потім ще раз мочити, щоб кошики плести.
Чекай.
Тут майстрів багато.
Всі в'яжуть, тільки в кожного свій почерк.
Як почерк на письмі — у кожного свій.
Цю працю механізувати майже не можливо.
Якщо б було можливо її механізувати,
то напевно давно б її механізували.
Нема таких станків, і навряд чи колись будуть,
щоб вони в'язали отак.
Щоб будь який виріб в'язали,
то тільки ручна робота.